I think the thing that most people will
know you for is the fact that you made a
really good video routine about brexit
and that I think became it went viral
and people a lot of people have watched
that and since then your career has
taken an interesting turn which we'll
get into but what I really like about
that video is I thought first of all
most people who watch that wouldn't know
this but you recorded it in central
London a very liberal comedy club where
I would estimate having played all of us
all three of us have played at many many
times you know 95% of the audience there
remaineth I would imagine and you got an
applause break and lots and lots of
laughter for what it's just a really
good comedy bit right one minute before
that I was doing remain jokes one minute
before then I was doing second
referendum jokes and the audience went
moving on that yeah and then it was just
I was like okay well I'm just gonna flip
it and I'm gonna do the other side and
they weren't with me on that as well but
that is the big problem it's the fact
that I went against the grain and did
something on the other that I dared to
do it and it doesn't it hasn't made any
difference it was funny it doesn't make
any difference it was popular it's just
like that's not what comedians say I've
had people call me I didn't want to talk
to me for an hour over give you what
else what you've done oops 400 word text
as to do realize what it's just blew me
away before we get to no no it's great
let me ask you this in terms of the the
political stuff because I've we've known
you for a long time I remember when I
started you know you've already been
going for quite a while I remember
watching you kind of do when I was doing
my first case card this guy's really
good comedian but you never used to talk
about politics in a way you weren't that
you were never political onstage what
was it that made you think well I
actually want to talk about the stuff is
that something that you suppressed
before because you knew what the
punishment would be or I just I figured
out what was going on I was like this
lady's and trying to get us out of here
if you knew she's pretending that she is
she's not and it was too funny what was
going on was too far I couldn't not
touch it it was all I was so sure that I
was like she's not trying to leave the
European Union she's just doing the
worst deal ever polite two years I'm
like
she's not trying and then the idea of
something simple like being in a Burger
King and trying to get out and your
friend the idea came to me and I was
Society it was his eyes in my head it
was funny and I was a sauna I'm doing
that and actually when I got to top
secret Nico who's the guy who runs the
show of a top secret on a Sunday and a
Tuesday he was like make everyone's
board a breakfast I don't mention any
breaks it's tough it was like everyone's
bored of it and I was like here but
that's the point it's like everyone is
everyone is sort of bored of it but
they're bored because they're just being
told the same thing they've been told
this was I mean this is like me and they
secretly know that it's not it's like
the Dave Chappelle with the judge Mr
Justice molesting everyone know he said
what we all think there's a laugh to be
had just from yeah going against the
grain even if it's you know only factual
people are just like oh my god he said
that I'm Shirley I remember the night
before you did it well the night you did
it we went for a coffee didn't we yeah
we use can be assist on this one
definitely yeah I remember yeah that's
my claiming credit we started writing
together we started going we started
it's decided to come up with ideas
together and the next day I came up with
my favorite bit of comedy I've ever done
yeah I would say that's got lots to do
yeah and then you went and did it and
then I just thought it was a great bit I
didn't even see I'll be honest with you
I don't even see it as being a proper
exit bit no I saw it being there's a bit
of pure observational comedy this is
where we are this is a ridiculousness of
the situation and you've got that is the
role of a comedian to observe and
present in a comedic way that we all
laugh and go that's true I think I got
in trouble cuz it's true true I think I
got in trouble because the reason he
wasn't really trying to do a good job to
get us how he ope I mean she'd come up
with a deal that was worse than the
remaining and I don't think I don't
think I had took her to used to do that
I don't understand how she was trying
you know saying yeah well what I was
asking before those but I'm curious
artists because
we're not very in my experience having
known you for a while you were not ever
political right and if I can tell you
after between gigs or whatever we just
used to talk comedy and play life and
stuff yeah but it seems to me now
particularly your YouTube channel as
you've you've become a political
commentator and why is that well I
realized that they look at they're gonna
smash me they're gonna smash everything
I work for they're gonna stop me doing
comedy because because I want to say
what I think is really going on and once
you realize that just everything else
doesn't seem so important it seems like
society's going off a cliff you know
we're all in a little rowing boat and
we're going off the edge of a waterfall
and I can see the edge and now I'm just
paddling backwards and if I saw why you
doing that maybe don't see the edge
sorry yeah if we really do live in a in
a country where you can't just go up
there and have a laugh and say what you
think without being utterly smashed
utterly smashed that's that's just not
fair
do you not I mean and I will do
something about it
[Music]